a dot org and click on public lives in
an uncertain world is former Treasury
Secretary Robert Rubens new memoir of
Washington and Wall Street Monday he sat
down with al hunt executive Washington
editor of The Wall Street Journal the
program is just over an hour
ok
welcome everyone to science my name is
Jessica einhorn and I'm the Dean here at
sighs we are delighted to join with the
Council on Foreign Relations in hosting
Robert Rubin to discuss his newly
published book let me hold up the copy
but you'll have more outside in an
uncertain world I'd like to start with a
special welcome to the Honorable Carla
Hills you stand up who has graced the
stage at size 44 Carl is here tonight
both as a friend of size and as vice
chair of the council with bob rubin
those of you who know Bob know that he
likes teamwork and he believes in
sharing leadership roles it's the right
person and chemistry can be found well
the council is indeed fortunate to have
this exceptional team working with Pete
Peterson as the leadership of our board
today al hunt will moderate our
discussion I'll introduce him in a
moment but I should mention this format
is Bob suggestion and it is evocative of
the book as secretary Bob Rubin was on
the receiving end of some pretty tough
media brawls during such times as the
debt ceiling standoff or the Asian
crisis but bob says that nonetheless by
the time he was leaving Washington he
found that some of the closest friends
and the people he respected most were
the journalists that he had come to know
over those years al hunt is executive
Washington editor for The Wall Street
Journal and Dow Jones he joined the
journal in 1965 as a reporter in New
York but didn't his quickly moved his
career to a focus on national politics
in our capital since 1972 his journal
responsibilities include the writing the
weekly editorial page column which I
think many of you know politics and
people and what you might not know is
he's also directing the papers polls Mr
Hunt is a member of CNN's capital gang
and
is written extensively on American
elections in 1999 he was the recipient
of the William Allen white foundations
national citation presented annually
that citation is one of the highest
honors in journalism with this extensive
background he's really the perfect
interlocutor for Bob Rubin as an offer
I'm here only for the welcome but I
can't leave the podium without saying
that from my perch in the finance area
of the World Bank I lived the years that
Bob Rubin describes so beautifully in
his book and so it was with special
interests that I read this wonderful
book giving generous credit to all his
associates in the government bob is
written a book that uses lively
narrative to illustrate and underscore
important concepts about how our economy
works about global interdependence the
nature of the policy process and the
complexity of the management role in the
public sector but most of all this is a
personal portrait of how a very
particular way of looking at the world
can career can span a career in both the
private and public sectors Bob Rubin
will be available after this event to
sign a book and for more on that let me
turn the stage over to our guests with
al hunt you can stay there a few buckets
I can get this hooked up right Dean
thank you very much it is really a
delight to be here can everybody hear me
in the back I I one time in print
referred to Robert Rubin is the most
successful Treasury secretary since
Alexander Hamilton and then I made the
mistake of doing that on the CNN
television show and my colleague Robert
Novak erupted insisting insisting the
back honor clearly belonged to Andrew
Mellon which was a debate that I really
relished I thought that was terrific
this is the Dean said is a is a
marvelous book it really is all sorts of
things I learned about Bob Rubin that
had nothing to do with with Mexican debt
crises or Asian debt crises or the
deficit he spent time in Paris in 1960s
and was a devotee of The Beat Generation
writers Jack Kerouac I can't imagine I
just can't imagine Douglas Dylan sitting
down with Jack Kerouac I just somehow
find that hard to believe I also found
out that we think of him as the great
graduate of Harvard College in Yale Law
School he was rejected by Princeton and
in one of his rare smart-alecky moments
after he graduated from Harvard he wrote
the Dean of Admissions to Princeton to
tell him he had graduated from Harvard
was going to the London School of
Economics and the Dean of Admissions
wrote back and said every year we try to
turn down a few people so Harvard can
have good students also that actually
bob was one of my two favorite Princeton
sir we have a son who's a junior in high
school which means that we are these
these high-pressure Washington parents
now who are panicked about our kid going
to school and went to a meeting a few
weeks ago and another Dean of Admissions
of Princeton was there and he told his
favorite he said the first year he got
there from Stanford that one of the
questions they had asked and the
application was what's been your most
significant intellectual experience he
said there's one kid he admitted that he
met him grades unseen because the kid
wrote back and said hey I'm 17 years old
I've never had an intellectual
experience that's why the hell I'm
applying to Princeton
so I first of all exactly not that I
don't not that I haven't forgotten not
being accepted but it just suits I am
surprised that this book ever came about
for a lot of reasons and I know they're
there number of people deserve a lot of
credit but I remember shortly after Bob
came to Washington we had had him to the
wall street journal's washington bureau
for a lunch and we were having it was a
one of those background sessions and at
one point someone asked him a question
and he said he said is this is this off
the record and we said yes it is we
thought this is really gonna be
interesting she's got a real Reuben so
after a stab she was off the record he
looked at us and said no comment that's
what I expected to see I was
delightfully surprised Bob start off by
telling us about the title in an
uncertain world what it what it meant
for once relevance was for government
and about your your view of I hope I can
pronounce this correctly probabilistic
you got it I'm not let me mention one
other thing though about that trip to
the to the journal editorial board cuz i
remember that i didn't come alone Gene
Sperling wouldn't let me go meet with an
editorial board loans no gene kadon sat
next to me and I would give it this was
true at every editorial board i went to
initially i would say something and then
gene would say of course what he really
meant to say it was a father but
eventually i was freed and allowed to go
places by myself I became convinced and
I think probably ten mentally I'm
Orientalist way anyway but I became
convinced as I went through college and
it was particularly influenced by a
course I took in philosophy with it just
a wonderful man named Rafael demos that
you in fact could not prove certainty
and that was kind of the gist of his
course it certainly is the view of
modern science that there is no provable
certainty and once you accept the notion
that there's no provable certainty then
it seems to me that leads you to
recognize the complexity of the world we
live in the issues we face and also
leads you to recognize or at least I
think it is recognized that all
decisions are
out probabilities and trade-offs and
risks and so the unser that the title of
book really has two meanings one is an
uncertain world in the sense that
everything is inherently uncertain for
the reason I just said there's no
provable certainty and the other is I
degree of something President Clinton
said at one point mm he's giving a
speech and he said that the economic
outlook is always uncertain but
sometimes are particularly uncertain and
and this is one of those times and I
think that very much continues in fact I
think it's even more uncertain some
respects today than it was at the time
that he's made those remarks so in both
respects that's the the genesis of the
title you know the cliche that Bob
doesn't need any introduction with
certainly test at night because it just
just don't to me I did not introduce him
but could I say one more thing yeah
larry summers with my deputy he was
deputy sector now he's president harbors
you know i was ones giving a speech to
actually rather large group and larry
got up to introduce me to get to the
toad podium he said and now Bob Rubin
was get up and then he sat down so I got
up and I said Larry let me thank you
effusive Lee for remembering my name
then I introduced myself I won't do that
here
that's the experience for my comes to
mind for you were treasury secretary you
were the the first head of the National
Economic Council in the White House 1993
Clinton came in you faced a pretty bad
economy huge deficits and a campaign
which had made certain promises and
certain commitments to various interest
groups and one of the fundamental
decisions you made in the beginning was
a deficit reduction would have a top
priority you made the Clinton made to
tell us how difficult it was to do that
because deficit reduction had never been
a very salient political issue it was
very difficult now but I think that what
happened and this is a little more in
the realm of politics and economics was
that you'd had these these deficits to
the 80s and there were people who were
talking about them i remember when Roger
Altman and I in the 88th time the 88th
convention was some kind of a meeting of
House members at the convention Roger
and I went and one of the House members
said Barney Frank actually said look you
all have been talking about deficits all
this time yet here we are in 1988 the
economy is doing fine don't you think
maybe you misunderstood what's going on
well it wasn't but about a year later
that the economy really started to slow
down I think there is absolutely no
question if you look at what happened
interest rates over that 89 90 91 92
period that the adverse fiscal
conditions that we had experienced
during the 90s I'm sorry during the 80s
we're having their I think predictable
effect and when the economy really
started to slow down and in very early
well 1991 interest rates did not come
down except a bit and the result was
that interest rates instead of falling
and generating recovery undermined
recovery and it was in that Jenna it was
in that framework that the 92 campaign
was run and the american pit is true
deficit reduction is very hard to
explain and the problems that are
associated with fiscal discipline all
that is very hard to explain in a way
that resonates politically but in that
context when the consequence was
actually being felt the American people
did come to understand what was
happening as a result of fiscal
discipline and as you may remember it
was very central to the campaign Paul
Tsongas I think in some ways made it so
and it was very central to President
Clinton's election and one selected that
then be
his threshold issue but unfortunately a
lie I do think that if you look back
over time it may only be I hope this is
not true but it may only be that
political discipline really is
politically fiscal discipline is really
politically resident when there is
trouble and right now I think we were in
a spate going Sachs put out a report
recently just a few days ago actually
and the first line of that report the
rough paraphrase is that the budget is
simply out of control and I think that's
true on the other hand continues to get
worse and worse and at least so far that
doesn't seem to be a political
coalescence around do anything about it
but you also note in the book that
President Clinton told you at one point
that it was important for him to
establish his bona fide ease and deficit
reduction so he could do other things a
Democrat had to meet that threshold test
not true of a Republican really is it i
mean george bush had to meet his has to
meet his with education No Child Left
Behind and the like there really isn't
much of a political incentive would you
think for for george bush or republican
to make deficit reduction essential well
there may not be an immediate political
incentive for anybody Margaret that is
getting this a rough paraphrase mark
Margaret Thatcher once said the
political discipline tends not to have
much political have much effect on
politicians because it's much easier to
cut taxes or increase spending and to
figure that the price for that is going
to be paid on somebody else's watch and
unfortunately I think that's true i
think the incentive for trying to for
trying to come to grips with i think has
now become a very serious threat to
economic future is the seriousness of
purpose one would hope ones leaders have
about our economy but in terms of
immediate politics it is true that it
has very little residence you you write
a great deal about the relationship the
very good relationship that you and
larry summers and others had with
chairman chairman Greenspan he said the
other day that that we need to have more
fiscal discipline than we need to do
something about the deficit but he said
it could all be it all should be done on
the spending side well what do ya
slightly i think what he said and this
again is a paraphrase not an exact quote
but it was referenced these very high
budget deficits and he said we're gonna
have to make very difficult choices and
our future depends on making those
choices and i think that is absolutely
right now he did say at the thought
you've done the spending side i don't
think that that's right i think they're
all kinds of services and and needs and
purposes that
American people want their governor
performed and for the garden perform
them they're going to have to have
adequate resources so I think that when
and furthermore we have an enormously
deep hole now so I think when the time
finally comes at our political system
does what inevitably is going to have to
do which is to come to grips with this
problem it's going to have to do it on
both the revenue side and the spending
side and longer they wait the worse it's
going to be for all kinds of reasons not
the least of which is that by time you
get to about twenty fourteen or so the
costs of the entitlement programs begin
to accelerate very rapidly because of
the baby boomer retirements we should be
preparing for that by retiring our debt
instead we're increasing our debt what
would you do on the spending side as a
Democrat well I don't care what I've
Democrat a Republican or whatever else
one might be in life I think that what
and without getting program-specific I
think that's okay yeah but I'm not I'm
not I'm going to stay program general
though I appreciate the opportunity but
I'll give an example what you shouldn't
do I think we should have a prescription
drug benefit that's my personal view you
can argue about it but if you have it
just pay for it we just put in place a
prescription drug benefit that's
estimated to cost about 400 billion over
the next 10 years that's an enormous
amount to begin with but that didn't but
the beginning of it for the next ten
years once these baby boomer retirement
start to accelerate that's starting
about 2014 it is estimated that will
cost us an average of two hundred
billion dollars a year that's two
trillion dollars over ten years and
which that's not paying for it and I
think that that is an absolute
abandonment of any sense of fiscal
discipline and I do think al that that
tracks back to these two big tax cuts
because I think what we had in the night
we're not i think what happened in the
90s of my judgment is you developed a
fragile but nevertheless politically
effective political consensus a--this
has the wrong word coalescence around
fiscal discipline but once you had these
big tax cuts and tax cuts that were far
have heavily tilted toward the most
affluent i think was impossible to
maintain that discipline because if
you're going to cut taxes and do it
particularly in a way that was so
heavily favored the affluent how are you
going to persuade anybody else to
maintain discipline what they want to do
and I think that had this terrible
indirect effect of undermining the
political coalescence we had let's come
back to
axes in a moment but but but again let
me just stay on spending is there any
area of spending without being being
being really that specific any area of
spending that ought to be reduced well
I'll say I'll say this so having spent
most of my career in the private sector
where there is a tendency to be
relatively disciplined while you going
to survive there in these days
particularly its competitive global
economy I do have to be very disciplined
about expenses I believe we absolutely
must have a very strong defense for our
country a military defense on the other
hand it's hard to me to believe that the
department that large if you could
really get at it in the kind of way that
people run large American companies
wouldn't have substantial savings that
could be made so that's one example but
i think my impression having been an
administration six and a half years and
watching how the politics of all this
work is that it's very difficult to do
on the tax area if you could would you
repeal all of the bush tax cuts i don't
think it matters so much what you do
specifically but i think you are going
to have to have substantial addition
revenues and i think it's only going to
happen one way and that is if you have a
president that takes the leadership
brings together both houses of Congress
and a bipartisan basis and they all sit
together and make what i think are going
to be extremely difficult decisions but
politically is substantively and if it's
only if they share the political burden
of doing that this is going to happen at
least in my judgment do you think
there's any then then you don't really
think the debate that's going on the
Democratic primary right now matters
much between I actually don't think it
matters very much truthfully I think
it's sort of i think that they are
debating it at least shows that these
are people who understand that we really
have an immense long-term fiscal problem
but i think the particulars of that
debate don't matter very much because i
think that the whole now said is before
mr. Peterman so i think the hole is so
big that when we we actually turn around
to fixing it we're gonna have to know
awful lot on the revenue side as well as
serious to the expense discipline so
they lead from this from this session is
Ruben says the Democrats are irrelevant
to what's going on no I think there's no
Oh No well that that of course is what I
learned to expect some extent by media
relations of Washington but let me see
but let me see if I use burly in the
front row us just say what Bob meant to
say yeah let me see if I could reframe
that slightly I think that you do see in
the Democratic candidates at least at
least in those that have a serious
chance again the nomination I do think
you see a serious focus on the
importance of dealing with this fiscal
issue and that is the beginning at least
of doing what needs to be done I think
the specifics of that debate at least in
my judgment are not really with the
issue lies do you have any preference
among that feel right now do I have a
preference amongst those who are running
I think what do you think the
probability is you in a specific answer
for me on that we live in uncertain
world but I can tell you one thing
that's virtually certain we're not going
to get what you like I guess that let me
ask you one more question about about
tax cuts you you argue very extensively
in the book that one of the great
benefits among others one of the great
benefits of your deficit reduction was
that eventually produce lower interest
rates which lower the cost of capital
and eventually I think it actually
happened much quicker than I
conservatives come back and say hey tax
cuts have the same effect that lowers
the cost of capital so why aren't you
know we tweet that's why we're producing
this great boom now well I don't think
tax cuts have a material effect on the
cost the cost of capital American
business yeah it may have some slight
effect if you cut capital gains tax
it'll-it'll it might have if it has any
effect at all it will be by contributing
something to the stock market because
otherwise I don't see why a lower tax
why lower taxes would increase would
decrease the cost of capital and
whatever effect that's going to have on
the stock market and that's a highly
debatable question but whatever fact on
the stock market is swamped by the
adverse effect on interest rates and
consumer and business confidence let me
go back to uncertainty for a moment you
you write about chairman Greenspan
and the in the book extensively and
about the relationship you haven't you
were crap you were count one
conversation that you had with the
Federal Reserve Chairman where he
challenged your assertion that
everything is uncertain because he said
that assumes a certainty and you replied
that that assertion that uncertainty is
unprovable actually proves that nothing
is is a certain we thought you guys were
talking about money supply and all that
fun stuff instead I give us your
evaluation of chairman Greenspan oh I
think I think extremely well I'm out for
four and a half years that was the whole
I wasn't white house two years for NF
Treasury but the four and a half years
that I was in Treasury Larry and Alan
and I had breakfast once a week Orson
cage need lunch but basically breakfast
once a week and then very often we'd
meet during the week when we had the
Mexican crisis or the asian crisis or a
whole host of other problems and in
those four and a half years not a single
not once did something leaked from those
meetings which for Washington is pretty
unusual but I think the world of him I
think he's very thoughtful he's got a
very good sense of humor it's a little
bit there you have to sort of find yield
curves funny but nevertheless which not
everybody does but I haven't just sort
of like that and so I kind of related to
it as i say not everybody would
necessarily relate equally to that and
he is it was a pleasure to deal with and
many it really was and alan once said i
think he actually said this to Time
magazine when they did that interview
you know that story I was that although
Larry and Al and I were very different
people in many ways we all put our egos
aside and we dealt with each other and
and and we kind and put our ideologies
and whatever else might be aside or
preconceptions it's a better word
preconceptions aside and tried to
analytically get to what seemed like a
sensible place to be and we function
that way together it actually worked out
very well it really did he's also very
outdated one other thing if I may he has
a remarkable commit facility is probably
the right word for reading data I think
I remember to mention the book once I
went in to see him and he were having
our breakfast and he said what do you
think of the latest shipments of some
kind of wheat I'd never heard of I said
well Alan I guess I missed that he's
always all the papers today well it
turned out there was a lie in some place
or
and then he read all kinds of meaning
into it it really had remarkable ability
to take data and read into it what was
happening economically yet that same
person gave the green light to those tax
cuts that you find so so offense well
using about the testimony in 2001 now
that testimony is this was was
interesting it is as you all in that
testimony chairman Greenspan expressed
concern about the surpluses and how
would we use them all and one thing
another but he also said in that very
same testimony that no matter what we
did we should not ever eat into the
Social Security surpluses that's the
same testimony well we have gone we not
only have we wiped out all the social
security surpluses in the next ten years
but we have gone massively beyond that
in our fiscal policy so in a sense he
did both things he expressed a concern
which I person did not share and I fact
I wrote at times I bet about it a
although not addressing Alan but just
the issue the question is whether the
surpluses might not be too large for own
good which I don't think was the case
but he also set up a very strong warning
against eating into the socio surpluses
which as I say not only we have gone
through them and we are vastly beyond
that in terms of the physical damage
we've done on the international front
mr. secretary you were greeted with a
crisis New Mexico crisis Billy from day
one you came in and I think you you you
wrote in your probabilistic I can't even
say the word from if someone told you
there's about a chance in three it would
succeed somebody else maybe Larry
Summers said there's maybe 50 50 chance
you would succeed what won't have been
what do you think would have been the
implications both economically and
politically if that if you're Mexican I
know you don't like the term bail out if
your Mexican package had not and not
succeed sorry i think referred it was
our mixing caper but any event i
referred to as our mexican financial
support program well what happened when
i got sworn in and it was in the oval
office there were many people there and
right after i got some more and i said
mr. president Larry and I need to speak
to him had something and what we just
did was to begin to
what we described him this this crisis
in in Mexico and then we said mr.
president if this crisis continues
unabated we think it could have enormous
adverse impacts on the United States
economically and in many other respects
we are strongly recommending that we
intervene and we provide I think at that
point it was 20 billion dollars or
something of that sort in support from
Mexico but we do need to tell you that
well we think this probably will work
there was certainly no guarantee and if
it doesn't work it could have not only
substantial economic consequences but it
could have horrendous political
consequences and he turned around to us
and he said look I know what the right
thing to do is we're going to do it and
we did and i think it was and it was
either in that conversation or was a
later conversation I forgotten at which
it was out when we needed to make
another step in the Mexican situation
when I said in the Los Angeles Times mr.
president has just published a poll we
said eighty-five percent of the american
people are against your going further
with respect to intervening in mexico
and he said look this is what we need to
do and let's do it did you fear that
that when the probably more serious
asian crisis occurred talking with
thailand a couple years later was that
was that even a tougher challenge and
did you contemplate what the
implications of failure there would be i
think they were both difficult
challenges in both substantively and
politically though i think politics of
mexico whole host of reasons turned out
to be more difficult than somebody
became ad hominem attack against me
which was first time I really
experienced that the asian financial
crisis i was it like but it feel like i
was terrific one of the great joys of
life it said well vac actually wrote a
column about you as i recall back it
wasn't the only time um that's why you
were here not Bob but any event I mean
you were very kind to that everybody it
I was surprised I wasn't ready for this
I mean I having been in white house for
two years I wasn't exactly an innocent
when it came to Washington and I've been
Volvo campaigns a lot before that and
I'd watched how people attack President
Clinton in ways that seem to me just
outrageous but it never happened to me
before and I could understand people
saying we shouldn't do this in
Mexico I felt very slowly we should we
shouldn't what we did which is a
different way and there were all kinds
of arguments I understood people making
but I must say when they start attacking
me and there were people in Congress
saying that I had a so this actually
happened that I had a secret Swiss bank
account that all I cared about I was
gonna go back to Goldman Sachs someday
and I was trying to develop good
relations with the clients somebody said
I still had a undisclosed economic
interest in Goldman Sachs that I
actually got from the hill and meet with
a congressman to explain to him
precisely what my arrangement was which
was the token zero economic interest up
or down in Goldman Sachs it matter to me
what happened at the goldman sachs and I
it took a little getting used to after a
while I sort of got it sort of a shrug
your shoulders point of view and it's
good thing I did because later on I was
given the opportunity to go through that
experience again around the debt limit
sailing and some other issues things
work very well Mexico work pretty well
in Asia didn't work so well with Russia
did it no and the book describes in
Russia this this sort of probabilistic
that I'll mention this problems approach
to decision making which is sort of how
I live my whole life and everything I've
done but if we particularly described in
the arbitrage area which I ran before
out in the early days of Goldman Sachs
and then we describe it in public policy
and in Russia we describe what was
really a very difficult decision because
on the one hand all of us felt that the
probability was that Russia was not
going to adopt their forms that Russia
needed to a job if this was going to
work because all the aid in the world
isn't then it isn't good of Welsh and
say well he a new world but nothing that
is realistically possible in terms of
aid and these kind of sport Frome's is
going to work unless the country takes
ownership and reform and was pretty
clear the Duma was their legislative
body was very unlikely do that on the
other hand they have something like I
think 10,000 nuclear weapons and it was
extremely important that the Reformers
in Russia feel that they were being
supported and the Russian people not
feel the West was abandoning them and
that was the weighing in the balancing
we had to do and we support an IMF
program feeling that there was probably
a pretty good chance it wouldn't work at
some point though when it became
absolutely clear the Duma was simply not
going to do what needed to be done and
we debated this I said look it seems to
me that we've now reached the point
which actually may be counterproductive
the community providing funds because
all it's going to do is enable those who
have money much of which might be listed
in Russia to
Bert their money into dollars and get it
out of the country and it's going to
absolutely undermine the credibility of
the IMF and that credibility is what we
have lived off in dealing with with the
asian financial crisis you all may not
remember this but the Russian bonds at
that time with trading it's something
like eighty percent yields or something
like that and the people who are buying
them we're actually explicitly saying
that they were taking a play on the
theory that we wouldn't have let a
nuclear power have the kind of economic
difficulties that would happen if in
fact I'm if not continue the program and
I said I just think don't think we have
a choice and we had a very big debate
about that and ultimately decided not to
continue not to continue well the IMF
discontinued their program with our
blessings we and the IMF very close so
with our blessings and Russia infected
default on a step but in some of the
other some of the other actions where
you did we did I know you hate the term
bailout I'm trying to think about
another term to use now but support
program what your critics address what
some of your critics talk about what you
address in the book to which is that you
did that they charge you were
insufficiently sensitive to the moral
hazard argument not just for countries
but for investors Glenn Hubbard for
instance the the bush economist said
that a lot of us might have to bail out
for bondholders who yeah I let's leave
as I personalities but a number of
people said no I think I think there is
a very serious moral hazard problem and
it was one that troubled me very deeply
moral hazard as you know is this this
notion and I think it's a correct notion
that if you provide government support
in these kinds of situations that
encourages creditors to be less careful
next time because they figure what the
heck they've supported if they if they
bail this I don't like the term either
but if they provide a support for over
in the first case that supplies support
firm in the second place I don't think
they would I actually know Wall Street
reasonably well I spent a lot of time
there and I know a lot of people there
and it's kind of world I'm pretty
familiar with I don't think anything
that we did in Mexico caused creditors
to be less careful in dealing with Asia
but I did become very concerned as we
got into the asian financial crisis that
at some point you could really have a
major moral hazard problem that the
creditors could really start to decide
look they're providing support and as
long as it's surprising support we don't
really
to worry about being careful in terms of
the credits that we were extending and I
I at least think and some people
disagree with me but I think had we go
ahead and Russia in the face of the Duma
saying they would not do it was needed
even for a reasonable minimal kind of
reform program that we might really then
have crossed a threshold and across the
threshold and moral hazard that we
should not across in fact I remember
saying some of the people at Treasury I
think those in the book I forgotten that
if I were still running which I did run
a very major trading operation of Wall
Street and we continue to support Russia
what the heck I'd go figure that
nobody's going to exercise a discipline
anymore and I'd probably go start buying
stuff myself but I knew on its own two
feet didn't make sense mm-hmm as well as
fiscal discipline and certain you know
moderate programmatic liberalism another
central tenet of Clinton nomics Rubin ah
mixes so Clint nomics is right he was
the unquestioned leader of our economic
team and I i think what history looks
back and President Clinton one of the
things they will say is that he really
understood the forces they would work
and what is I think really a very
serious significantly changed the
economy from what it was say 15 or 20
years ago and very pro free trade more
so than this administration recognition
of globalization what are your
Democratic critics however were not
yours but of this maybe of yours too but
this is joe stiglitz Nobel prize-winning
economist who says that unless altered
globalization is not only going to
succeed in promoting development but
it's going to continue to create poverty
and instability how do you answer that
uh I don't well haha my basic answer is
I think that globalization trade
liberalisation and integration have
produced enormous good for very large
numbers of people and we were very
fortunate we inherited from President
Bush elder a lot of initiatives in in
the in the trade area that we were able
to carry forward and I think that was
one of President Clinton's very
significant accomplishments and as I say
that the momentum had begun with the
elders elder President Bush I think
however it is also true that what you
need to do if you're going to get the
broad-based participation in growth
that it seems to me ought to be one of
the objectives and all of this and also
have the political support to continue
with globalization is you've got to have
sort of what I tend to think of as a
parallel agenda markets by their own
nature very nature are not going to meet
many of the needs that are pretty
central to both economic development and
broad-based sherry and growth education
healthcare legal framework regulation
the rest though seems to me what you
need to have is trade liberalisation
globalization all that combined with
robust programs and in the kinds of
areas i just mentioned and that means
government must also play a very
important role a lot of the talk about
outsourcing of jobs did I just say one
more thing when NAFTA was so enormously
controversial and President Clinton came
back from a vacation I think it was and
I forgotten exactly when it was but it
was March 94 or something like that he
stood up in the east room and he had the
living presence behind him except
President Reagan who wasn't well his
presentation wasn't there either but the
others were there and he gave a speech
about NAFTA how important it was to
continue with NAFTA what he said was and
I think he's absolutely right he said
the advocates of less a fair to markets
are not all right or wrong and the
advocates of government programs and how
to hold right or wrong what you need are
both together and it's that combination
that's the right path forward and I
think that was exactly right I was going
to ask you about outsourcing a lot of
its focused on on the industrial sector
but you now or top muckety-muck of a
very big important financial services
you're doing a lot of outsourcing of
jobs lost so aren't you is that it is
that a short-term problem for the for
the American kind we can have a jobless
recovery because of that among other
factors I don't know if I'd call it a
problem it I don't think it's a
short-term phenomena no I think you do
have a new reality and at the two pieces
to it one is you have real-time
communication so that you can do
software development in China or India
and get the results of instantaneously
and the other is you now have very large
numbers hundreds of millions of
well-educated people who are able to
perform the value added knowledge jobs
every bit as well as our well educated
people can who live in very low wage
economies and I think the consequences
you can know I think this is a
phenomenal
continue you will continue to see
certain kinds of knowledge based jobs
being as you called it outsourced but I
do think that if you look historically
at our economy this is a very agile
economy it's a flexible economy doesn't
enormous and because of cultural embrace
of change and as this is happen to our
history I think that once again will
adjust and we will develop new areas and
new jobs and all the rest and
furthermore china and india's gdp work
on amis will grow and their incomes will
grow and wages will go up and they'll
become bigger markets for us and the
wage differentials will narrow pop you
but there could be but there will be
there's no question there will be
adjustment adjustment difficulties and
dislocations which is why we also at
least in my judgment absolutely must
compile at least we should combine with
our trade liberalization policies
domestic parallel genders well a strong
focus in education in the inner cities
training help for those who are
dislocated the rest it's that
combination that seems to me is the path
we need to go go forward you've been
around some some remarkably smart people
going back to Gus levy at Goldman Sachs
tell us about Bill Clinton's intellect
capacity strengths and weaknesses let's
focus a little more on the strengths but
ok now I President Clinton is remarkable
I think in many respects I have great
regard for president couldn't I think
comes through in the book I would guess
it does yeah well I do I wrote an op bed
I think it's the only hot bet I wrote
while i was in treasury as far as I can
recollect in which I talked about
President Clinton decision make I name
is remarkable decision maker out he
would sit with us in these meetings and
he would pull out from us all the pros
and cons whatever issue was dealing with
and particularly want to hear about the
people who disagree on to hear the views
disagreed with his and then he would
pull it all together he'd process it now
since um people that can lead to
indecisiveness in his case it didn't he
was also decisive and he made a decision
when he made them he fought to implement
them so yeah I have great regard for
Brooklyn he must also have something
pretty close to photographic memory I
remember once and I don't think this
isn't the book but maybe there's that
forgotten but I remember once Larry and
I went to see about something other
was and presently and just read some
book some very current book and
economics Larry it so happens have read
it too there's larry summers with my
deputy now he's president harbored and
larry was the youngest person in the
modern history of harvard to get tenure
and he's the Kings got ahead in the
shoulders and and we went in there we
did whatever it is we did and then
President couldn't I guess ask Larry if
he's seen this book and Larry said I
just read it and so presidency I just
read it too and President Clinton
summarize it we walked out Larry said
you know he did a better job summarizing
I could have and that wasn't something
Larry would have said that so readily so
so it was really no I don't mean no it's
just that's it was easiest Clinton has
extraordinary intellectual gifts and I
think he's a good decision maker and I
think he had the courage of his
convictions and a lot of very tough
political issues he made the decisions
he thought were right and and he came
close to suffering grievously
politically for some of them there was a
reduction program past what two votes in
the house was tie in the Senate NAFTA
was very unpopular with a lot of our
Democrats I think wrongly could I think
was very important thing to do WTO China
accession to the WTO and so forth but as
some of his early problems were for this
enormously smart man who had been around
so much really staffed is government
poorly in the beginning and present
company certainly excluded but the White
House staff was not very strong that
national security team is not very
strong in the beginning which really set
the tone for some of the problems that
he they had later why was that why was a
man this able and this you've been
around quite a while yeah I don't know
if I let me i'll give you my view of
whatever its i think i would
characterize a little different unit as
you know from reading the book Mack
McLarty it was somewhat people in
Washington the time had to two minds of
mad Mac Mac was our first chief of staff
I thought in certain respects Mac really
they're very good job and I think was a
way that washing had a hard time
relating to which was that he encouraged
people to work together and a journalist
once said to me and I think it's true
that we probably never could have made
the NEC work with the kind of
authoritarian chief of staff that some
other presidents have had but Mac let it
flourish and let it work I had a great
deal of respect for mac
I think what we didn't have and I guess
it was because President Clinton hadn't
been in Washington before but what we
didn't have it in our initial White
House we didn't have nearly enough
Washington savvy and we should have had
as a whole bunch more people who really
knew how Washington worked and who were
in a position may be working under mac
for example in a position to impose in
the right word but to see to it that the
White House function in a way that was
much more congruent with the ways in
which Washington work and I think we
lacked a certain discipline which
unfortunately had much more effect on us
than it should have it a lot of was an
inconsequential thing remember the
haircut thing in LA I don't even know
what the facts were but allegedly
president got a haircut in on a tarmac
or something in a delays and traffic
although was inconsequential compared to
the important substance of things we
were doing but I got a great deal of
pressed and infected the way we were
seeing we're going to open this up and
just say how would a Hillary Clinton
presidency be different than a bill
clinton presidency well I and I think I
say this in the book I think the world
of Hillary I she also was very smart
this is a person with a heck of a good
head on her shoulders their Styles a
little bit different perhaps I like her
enormously I think she'd be a terrific
president but she's not established that
but how she's not running well she's
very bright so in that respect she'd
she'd be the same I think she'd have a
harder edge style to her and I think
frankly is not necessarily so bad you
remember in the book there was one thing
I think one of the Clinton love to
engage with people and very often I
think in the very process of engaging
with them because he would ask them
questions he was sort of try to elicit
their point of view they came away
thinking he sort of agreed with him and
then they would be misled they would
sort of came away with that feeling not
because he was deliberately misleading
just that was his his way of engaging
with people and then later they would
feel that he had misled them because he
wound up doing something different than
they thought they were going to do I
think with Hillary they would be
probably very little uncertainty about
what her what her
who is were you told that story as a
matter of fact in the book but you know
right now about how you had told him
after one meeting with you afterwards
the minute I said no mr. president I
used to do when I was at Goldman Sachs
and if you had been my client and we're
just minh city with newt gingrich which
we had been doing and you asked me how
how you thought you did i would say you
know i don't think you did very well i
think they just knock that they're gonna
think they're going to roll all over you
and he said what do you mean i was very
tough and I didn't tell you before mr.
president they're going to think that
you're just going to roll over you and
then Harold Ickes told me later that
that the president said to him you know
Bob Rubin told me the following do you
think it really was that way and Harold
tell you who's got some questions here I
know their loss there's a microphone
coming around so just raise your hand hi
my name is simon kennedy i covered at
current treasury / bloomberg news in
your book you talk a lot about
credibility all about confidence in the
particular when discussing message when
discussing policy given the deficits
steel tariffs that kind of an opaque
dollar policy has this administration
squandered some of the credibility in
the confidence that describe Bureau your
tenure at Treasury well I don't know
that you you you this I don't think that
I put it that way because you're Trina's
if there's sort of a storehouse of
credibility that's there and then
somebody inherits it and squanders that
our builds on it I think every
administration builds or doesn't build
its own credibility I think in terms of
policy issues and I've said this before
so I'm just repeating myself I think
we're enormously on the wrong track
fiscally I don't think we should have
had steel tariffs in the first place i
mean i just read the papers out they may
come off I don't understand the China
textile decision I think it's a shame
the dough around failed i don't think
that i think i think bob zealots a very
capable guy so i would not i think he's
very capable guy but I think we should
exert leadership to to get that back
together again as you know that's the
multilateral trade negotiation that's
supposed to bring the developing
countries more into the system so I
think in many very important fronts and
in terms of economic policy I just think
on the wrong track
carlos asada foreign policy magazine
with the benefit of hindsight um what do
you think you could upper should have
done during those six and a half years
to head off the crisis and corporate
governance the US no faces you know it's
it's an interesting question I don't
think that anything we particularly
could have done Arthur Levitt as you
know was chairman the SEC did want to
take some measures with respect to the
accounting profession but I don't think
there's anything particularly could have
done if you look back over financial
history of this country but and by the
way the same is true in Europe and Japan
so it seems to be true sort of without
regard the corporate governance systems
periodically there are space of these
kinds of of developments and I think
it's probably something pretty basic and
human nature and I think that the key is
to once these things surface to address
them as quickly and as effectively as
possible and to do so in a way that
hopefully responds to the to the
problems have developed and minimizes
the probability they're having of them
happen again I also think it's very
important to do in a way it doesn't
undermine the strength of our system
because I think we do have a corporate
governance system that enables CEOs to
organize CEOs and management's to be
flexible to take risk to make change to
adapt to a changing world and I think
would be a shame if we actually think
we've done so far as okay I think I
think sarbanes-oxley was sensible I
that's I think that's fine but I think
we don't want to do is it to create the
kinds of impediments to growth that I do
think for example the German corporate
governance system is created in Germany
and and and mind you in Europe they also
have these kinds of problems so that I
think there's something just very
fundamental human nature it's going to
cause it happen periodically and and
when it does I think absolutely and
imperative Lee we need to address it
quickly thoroughly and effectively I
don't think anything we could have done
that would have I don't think anybody
could have foreseen what was happening
in the in these situations well that's
that's on the corporate governance The
Wall Street issued a little bit
different the research investment
banking is kind of interesting because
that was something that
the relation between those two was
something everybody knew about the
regulator's knew that media knew
everybody the industry knew and whatever
reason nobody saw is a problem and the
Mason would be because you had this
enormous boom market from 1982 until
March of two thousand and it was only
after problems developed that it was
seen as a problems and I can't give you
answers to why it was that nobody all
these vast numbers of people's
regulators people in the north and no
one identified it as a conflict until
until problems developed now once they
was identified it would address very
quickly and I think effectively
additional public reasons can I take it
back to Russia for a minute well we come
to a point where Putin begins throwing
tycoons into jail and sits on the media
to make sure that isn't do you begin to
wonder or worry about the experiment in
Russia with free markets and democracy
and whether Russia is a good investment
for America well I I think that I'm no
great expert in Russia but I think that
what's happened with the with the oil
company and with its CEO in Russia is
troubling and I think the point it makes
is a point that we worried about all
through our interactions with Russia
which is that it is a country that never
had in some sense never really had a
rule of law because you had the Tsar and
then you had the revolution and then you
had Soviet government and what it
suggests to me is that this transition
is going to take time but I don't think
the answer is to turn back the clock on
market-based economics I think that
makes sense but I do think that it's
just and I actually don't think it's a
bad investment for America I think that
we need to be day / the more involved we
are with Russia the better in my opinion
because I think it's likely to encourage
rather than rather rather than the
country the development of a rule of law
and legal framework and all the rest but
it's like it at least to me that all of
this suggests that this is a process
it's going to take time okay
Jeremy hauschka by inference you said
I'll make the leap of inference of what
you said about we need both free market
and government so starting off with the
comparison of NAFTA what it has done in
the ten years the numerous criticisms
from poor working people in Mexico and
all the globalization complains that
there are currently that they do not
involve the grassroots and input from
the people what more can be done and
what should be done now in the future to
address these problems well let me start
by saying that while it is true there is
enormous poverty in Mexico and there's
in an income divided that it seems to me
is not long-term sustainable I think it
is also true that Mexico has benefited
very substantially from NAFTA in fact
more so with the peso crisis than with
that i think would probably well I
shouldn't say probably because I don't
know but what might have happened in
Mexico after the early 95 crisis began
if it hadn't been for NAFTA and if NAFTA
hadn't integrated the two countries the
way that it has is they might have gone
back to what they did in 82 which is to
super to impose a a policy of statism
and protectionism and as you may
remember they basically had was referred
to as a lost decade in this case they
were back in the capital markets and
something like seven or eight months I
don't remember exactly and in the 80s i
think it was seven years before they got
back in the capital markets so I think
NAFTA I think NAFTA served Mexico and
the Mexican people very well but I think
Mexico has a whole host of issues that
need to be dealt with and I totally
agree what you say or at least I'll
infer from what you said which is that
they have enormous no didn't matter if I
drop this thing will find now we'll find
out yeah I think it Jess I think they're
doing it's a c-span are you okay you're
okay okay there okay I'm okay I'm sure
okay I'm okay she's got a panic book
okay I do think that they need to have a
set of policies that will greatly
broaden participation and grow think
about property more effectively more
generally I think that we have got to
both very substantially increased
foreign assistance and we have to find
ways and this is not easy ways to use it
more effectively to anomaly to be
effective but to encourage developing
countries to put in place the kinds of
policies education systems health care
and the rest that will along with growth
effectively address poverty
I think too often by the way the
advocates of globalization have
underemphasized this other whole other
set of concerns and those who focus on
the other set of concerns have failed to
recognize the enormous contribution that
globalization trade have made for
example China hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of millions of people have been
brought out of poverty in China by
virtue of its global integration
although they still have enormous issues
ahead of them both the economically and
politically it must be journal Sally
it's pits are good for the system or not
al what do you think you know I think
he'd be a great running wait with
Hillary don't you how you made it worse
not better well David I work for an
organization that is regulated by eliot
spitzer so i will let me respond to that
in a generic sense i think that it is
imperative lee important for our system
to be effective and to work to have
effective regulation and when the kinds
of issues that developed over the last
few years develop to have them addressed
very quickly clearly at some points the
SEC was not doing what it needed to do
and spits a field avoid having said that
I don't think that it is efficient or
effective or in the interests of our
economy or society to have a financial
services industry that has the vast that
with a vast multiplicity of overlapping
regulators and so somehow other it seems
to me that that is an issue that has to
be addressed
is that fully satisfactory David know
you know you know the answer Bob can we
get Alice over here we'll come back
Thank You Alice Rivlin Brookings
Institution Bob you say in the book I'm
going back to the 94 election but you
say we failed to sell the deficit
reduction package we put it together we
were so exhausted we didn't get out and
sell it as well as we might have and
everybody thought that it was only a tax
increase and not spending reduction and
maybe that contributed to the loss in 94
but my question is why do you think the
Clinton program or the Clinton
administration lost the Congress in 94
and what would have been different if
they hadn't why wasn't the Republican
majority really very helpful in getting
some of the things that Clinton was for
on trade and on Deficit Reduction
through well let me answer that in two
pieces if if I may ask why do we lose in
94 I think that they're probably a lot
of I think that they're probably a lot
of factors that entered into that and
I'm not a political analyst but I do
think at least one of them and I
describe this in the book is that we put
in place this as Alice said and alice by
the way was absolutely central figure in
putting all this together and and in
driving our focus on on fiscal
discipline we put this program out and
then we sort of went on to some extent
to other things and those who were
opposed to it got into the field and
started characterizing it as a tax
increase and in fact as I said at the
beginning of this it was it was an
income tax increase on the top
one-point-two percent of Americans but
when Diane Feinstein ran for the Senate
in 94 she told me that there was a poll
she took a poll in California and
forty-two percent of the people who
responded that California poll thought
their income taxes have been increased
in 1993 that shows how effectively our
program was mischaracterized and have
that stuck in people's minds Gene
Sperling to tell me what you want to do
in all these things you want to try
control the prism through which
something is seen well this prism was
fashioned by the opponent's to the
program before we really got back into
the field I think Alice no I don't agree
the about the 94 election I think that
had we succeeded I think President
Clinton would continue exact on exactly
the same track with respect to
everything fiscal and in fact as you
remember one of our problems was fending
off and this gets a little bit later in
the game but fending off once they
surplus developed in 98 fending off the
proposals of some to use that surplus
for tax cuts and President Clinton if he
was we should retire the debt and
prepare the federal budget capability to
deal with these looming retirement sand
entitlement payments i think that was
exactly right trades a difficult issue
look trade is a very difficult issue and
has out suggested earlier in discussion
it's particularly difficult right now i
don't think that either party is
behaving in exactly the fashion that i
would choose to see the bay but that's
my view i really do believe very
strongly in trade liberalization we had
passed NAFTA by the time congress
changed hands and i think having done
that i think we probably would have
accomplished in trade yeah i think we
would've accomplished the same things we
did accomplish and and the congress now
it's come to think of it the Congress
denied President Clinton fast-track
Authority which you know was this
expedited Authority for dealing with
trade so I think we might actually have
fared better had he won the Congress and
lost it but that's just who knows what
you got us get a fungus gentleman over
here has been asking him raising his
hand for a long time my name is Jang
Geun Joe I'm a second year student mr.
Rubin I have two questions to you
because you mentioned China several
times my first question is prime
minister when java the new prime
minister is coming to Washington soon
regarding the Chinese renminbi exchange
rate do you have any comment about it
the second question is do you think the
trade relation between
the United States and China we are
becoming a issue in the campaign in the
election I actually met the new prime
minister in fact it may be that our new
CEO Chuck Prince and I were the first
Western business people to meet him we
went to China and saw him we spent a
good part of our meeting discussing the
exchange rate I believe in flexible
exchange rates and I think the world
would be well served by having flexible
exchange rate regime having said that I
can understand the Chinese point of view
where they might want to gradually move
into that as opposed to doing suddenly
though I think they'd be well served by
having a flexible exchange rate having
said that although the trade imbalance
with the United States is enormous about
125 billion or something surplus on
their part the global ounce is not that
large I think that their global trade
surplus is about 25 billion or some such
number the wall street journal editorial
page I don't really site in economic
issues but the wall street journal
editorial page said that they expect
personally directed at me though I don't
think if you as being part of the
editorial group but who knows that
they're going to have a deficit next
year in a global basis I don't know
that's right but I think it is quite
likely they're gonna have an even
smaller surplus so I don't think I think
that the the the importance of the of
exchange rate flexibility in China has
been vastly overstated although I think
on balance it is the right track for
them to go in I'm sorry your second
question was there's the phone so I
think we yeah I think Trey's gonna be
big I think rhetorically at least going
to become a very big issue because I
think there's enormous anxiety around
the country about jobs and about
outsourcing and about a lot of other
issues I think protection them is
exactly the wrong way for us to go I
think it'd be enormously
counterproductive and I think we need to
have a sound domestic policy and a whole
host of areas but most importantly and
most fundamentally we have got to
reestablish a sound long-term fiscal
policy both for economic well-being and
so that we can have the capabilities for
the education and training and all the
rest that we're going to need we're
going to be competitive in that in the
years ahead i'm going to ask a final
question because unfortunately we have
to we have to end this but i was having
lunch in june of two thousand with rich
daily mayor of chicago who was one of my
favorite politicians in the country and
could probably botch up pronunciation of
probabilistic because
badly as I have but I asked him tell me
your top two choices for Al Gore's vice
vice presidential selection and he said
bob rubin and bob rubin why is that such
a bad idea of any of you rejected I know
you do why oh I think well for a lot of
reasons first place i cannot i have been
her I the first political campaign ever
worked on well no that's not true but
the first presidential came to have
worked on was nineteen eighty it wasn't
that much involved with somewhat 84
hours new state finance chairman for
Monty I've actually been around some
presidential campaigns I am woefully
ill-suited for electoral politics and in
just all kinds of ways so I think that
would be just a terrible idea I also
think something I remember something Bob
Strout said to me Bob and my judgment
about his sage and sound and savvy as
anybody you're going to run into in
Washington when Bill Bradley was
thinking running for the Presidency this
was I know maybe was 88 could have been
92 I don't remember but was sometimes
and I Bob and I both agreed how terrific
guy Bill Bradley was which I do think
and thought then think now and Bob said
but if he runs for president the press
will repaint him so he won't recognize
himself in a mirror and I think it's
true I think of Al Gore firstly I was
totally unsuitable for electoral
politics leaving that aside if he wanted
me at all it would have been because he
thought I had some markham of
credibility and who knows how much but
least some on economic issues and i
think as soon as I became a political
figure i think i would have lost all
that credibility still a little bit that
he might have thought he was getting he
would have lost it would have evaporated
to him well i'll go back and explain to
rich deal he doesn't understand about
politics that's well I was ahead let me
say I spent a fair bit of time in
chicago so i will not exceed to that
characterization of what i said but any
of it i'm going to turn it back to the
Dean
something in the book where bob rubin is
called to be asked to come down at the
head of the NEC and he mentions in a
book that talks a lot about each wife
and that's beautiful dedication that
perhaps he should have consulted with
her a little bit before he said yes
absolutely so maybe in regard to Alice
question I opened this wonderful event
by welcoming the Council on Foreign
Relations let me close it by speaking a
little bit to our students here at size
and size we are educating leaders for
lives in public and private sector for
leadership in those areas and I can't
think of a better figure in Bob Rubin to
give you an experience in what lies
ahead of you I suggest that you read
this book which will be for sale and be
signed by bob rubin after this session
over winter break you will enjoy it and
you'll return infused with a passion for
the opportunities that a life that
combines both the private and public
sector can bring and to al hunt the
wonderful journalist whose friendship
began with critical discussions in the
print throughout the years and ended up
in the kind of conversation that we have
today we also have a wonderful
experience so thank you very much to
both of you
robert rubin is currently a director of
citigroup in an uncertain world is
published by Random House on the web at
Random House com